hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren heute machen Sandra weil das bin
ich und ich endlich mal wieder eine
nicht lachen Challenge mit tiktok Videos
war für mich eigentlich schon Feierabend
weil ich will ja keine haben die denn
vorher fressen kann
ein Mädchen geknallt das gestottert hat
war fertig bevor sie nein sagen konnte
so liebe Leute gleich heißt es Party
times seid mit dabei
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Bruder wie kann das sein du hast gerade
deine Ticket gezogen
lernen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
eine Pizza in den Ofen und stellt eine
Kamera davor um zu beobachten wann sie
fertig ist während er Fernsehen guckt
doch einfach auf die perfekte Farbe
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die Mutter von Ronaldo gerade den
Wechsel von Ronaldo zum FC Bayern
verraten
banana bitte
[Musik]
ey schon wieder übelst besoffen hier auf
dem Glühwein und dann ist ja einfach mal
aufgekommen Alter
geht dann ist echt lange
hallo Ich lachst du Pause machst
hallo hallo hallo
[Musik]
nicht böse gemeint dicker aber vallah
keine für dich denken
aber ich hatte sein Vater letzte Nacht
ist so scheiße beim Abschreiben ich
schreibe
keine Ahnung verstehe ich nicht
[Musik]
jeden Tag in der Hood Bro guck mal ich
laufe mit mit mit mit mit
Mehl durch die Hund braucht wie weit ist
der Mond von der Erde weißt du das wie
weit
Fahrer zu weit
sagen genau ungefähr einfach schätzen
eine Million Kilometer
wenn du dich fragst wie ich es mir
leisten kann an einem Montag in London
ein Espresso zu trinken dann habe ich
hier die Antwort für dich ich gehe
arbeiten und habe Urlaub
kennt sich das Ganze Idioten diese
Videos machen will Mädchen mit
Bommelmützen so diese Bommeln Mützen und
so ich will dann so drauf drücken dann
so tut tut sein und die lässt sich dann
so süß und dann bin ich kippe so ein
linken Haken essen
möchte ich immer wieder kleine Tattoos
Hinzufügen von schönen Moment
schwarz am Anfang war auch nur eine
Linie
ich bin den Typen so witzig
AP
Bahnhof
habe ich groß
ach was erstmal ein Bier
ich putze mir die Zähne mit links und
laufe dabei rückwärts die Treppen hoch
okay auch gegen Alzheimer und die
spielinstrumente ist auch gut fürs
Gehirn was mich jetzt aber gerade extrem
aufregt ist dass Sie den Weg komplett
neu gemacht haben der andere war doch
noch gut das verstehe ich auch nicht
dicker ja den Weg hier neu gemacht so
mit so Schutt dicker der andere war
vollkommen in Ordnung warum haben wir
das geändert meine Schwester
und ich
machen jetzt eine leckere
weihnachtsbesinnung mit selbstgemachten
Apfelbrot und Plätzchen lecker lecker
mit toller Sicht auf unserem
Weihnachtsbaum und die noch nicht fertig
gegrippe mein lieblingsinfluenza i feel
so aufgehoben irgendwann
vorbei vorbei ja jetzt mal no job wieso
kann so eine Oma tiktok bedienen Alter
was reimt sich auf Pfadfinder
katzengeräusche Bruder das ist ein Pferd
dazu ja heute ist warm und gestern war
kalt
warm hier rausgeht ihr habt vor nur ein
Bier zu trinken
was reimt sich auf Gerd
ein Adler er versucht hat zu fliegen
hast du versucht einzuspert deutsche
Sprache schwere Sprache
challen meine lieben Freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat dann lasst gern einen
Daumen hoch unter dem Video da abonniert
meinen Kanal und Klick auf die Glocke
weitere Videos nichts verpassen ich bin
heute Abend live auf Twitch bzw jetzt
gerade 18 Uhr spiel ich mit Sandra
Minecraft schön schön schön schalte
gerne ein schaltet ein liebe Leute
so und jetzt geht alle zur Therapie nach
den Videos ciao